what's in this cave down here NFS tell  people not to go too far in there it's  pretty dangerous Aaron it aren't you it  doesn't seem that page seriously it's  completely fine in here damn it that  storm knocked out the phone line I used  to talk to the service which means we're  cut off i'll see what i can do you think  you'll take to it being out here the  isolation gets to people i don't talk to  the other lookouts as much as i talk to  you not in the same way what made me so  special two young women have been  reported missing you're probably the  last person to have seen them hey  carrots somebody cut the comms what I'm  out here and the wire is cut clean  through wait you're already there you're  not in your tower no I'm not then you is  please welcome Adam Boyes